depuis samedi les réactions n'ont cessé
de se multiplier preuve que la question
passionne la ctm a lancé une
consultation pour doter la martinique
d'un drapeau et d'un hymne il faut
présenter les propositions sur le site
du côté des opposants politiques
on remet en question la démarche ne suis
pas contre qu'on trouve qu'on essaie de
trouver des des identifiants commun à
tout le peuple mais je me dis que c'est
peut-être pas l'urgence du moment
sachant que ce qui est important c'est
qu'à travers toutes les actions que l'on
peut mener pour contribuer à la quête
identitaire de ce pays et contribuer à
être pour pouvoir rencontrer l'autre
mais pour le moment on constate que que
j'ai peur que ça soit une fumée une
fumée qui masque tout le reste des
problèmes à droite c'est le choix du
vocabulaire qui interpelle un
vocabulaire nationaliste
il faut qu'on fasse la différence entre
un drapeau est un emblème sommes tout à
fait en droit on discute on avoir un
emblème pour la martinique mais poser la
question du drapeau s'est posé la
question de la souveraineté que ce qui
pose la question le par cette question
franchement tout simplement
même séparés un hymne est dure à
posséder attributs d'une nation donc si
on veut qu'ils aient une nation
martiniquaise qu'on le dise franchement
puisque l'hymne et le drapeau sont des
attributs d'une nation ce week-end les
partisans du drapeau rouge vert noir ont
fait connaître leur opposition à la
démarche estimant que c'était une
manière d'écarter les couleurs qui
commence à s'implanter dans le paysage
francis carole adopté le rouge vert noir
pour le palima il ya longtemps il n'est
pas à l'origine de la consultation
mais il voit une opportunité d'abord il
ya une forte demande de signes
distinctifs pour l'amérique et ça c'est
rassurant à toute la société
deuxième question qui est pendante
le drapeau vert noir existe certes mais
il n'est pas encore adoptée par
l'ensemble de la population
donc troisième élément c'est que et le
processus d'adoption des drapeaux sont
toujours des choses extrêmement complexe
nous créons l' espace de débat c'est ce
qui fonde amateurs un espace de débat
éclairé et que chacun peut faire ses
propositions y compris ceux qui comme
moi sont partisans du drapeau où j'ai en
moi que l'on soit pour le rouge vert
noir ou pour une autre combinaison de
couleurs il faut en tout cas se dépêcher
pour proposer un drapeau et un hymne la
consultation ne dure qu'un mois elle
sera clôturé le 28 décembre